one when you do this you're usually
doing the silic in a pre-algebra algebra
class you're looking for a pattern and
so you say okay the x-values these are
what I'm putting into the function and
the y-values that's what's coming out so
if you just look at it here you can see
hmm I'm going from seven to four eight
outputs five nine outputs six and ten
outputs seven so by looking at it you
can see that we're actually subtracting
3 7 minus 3 is 4 8 minus 3 is 5 9 minus
3 is 6 and 10 minus 3 is 7 so we can see
that our equation or function is y
equals x which is our input minus 3 and
that gives us our y-value of our output
so X is what we're putting in and we're
taking away 3 and we get Y is their
output okay this one's kind of easy but
we'll get this a little more challenging
ones here so number two what you can see
here is it's a little bit trickier to
tell what's happening like 6 outcomes
1770 in put 20 comes out 8 23 926 we
might not see a pattern right away but
what you can do with these problems is
you can look at what is happening to go
from one Y value to the next Y value
okay so here you can see I'm adding 3 to
get from 17 to 20 I'm adding 3 again to
get from 20 to 23 and I'm adding 3 again
to get from 23 to 26 so you can see
that's consistent right and we can see
that with the X values I keep going up
by one up by one and up by one so it
looks like for every increase in one on
the X okay the 3 is going up the Y is
going up by 3 right so what we can do is
we can say hmm it looks like what I'm
doing is I'm tripling the input okay I'm
multiplying the input times 3 but we
have to make a little bit of an
adjustment so let's look at this 6 times
3 is 18 but you can see our output is 17
6 7 times 3 is 21 but again this is 28
times 3 is 24 this is 23 you can see we
have to make an adjustment we have to
subtract 1 so this is going to be the
equation that represents you know this
input/output table so again what you do
is you look at the change in Y over
the change in axe so you make a fraction
and that's giving you what's called the
slope or the rate of change but at this
level when they usually present these
input-output tables you haven't gotten
yet to this equation that you'll be
learning in a little bit which is the y
equals MX plus B so at this stage
they're just trying to help you out
understand you know how to recognize
these patterns okay the last one number
three that I've written here is again
you can see what's happening is we're
going up by one up by one again up by
one again and with the X values we're
going up by two this time C four to six
six to eight and so here we can see that
the change in Y is an increase of one
for every change in X which is an
increase in two so what we have here is
we have y equals one-half X so one-half
times our input now you can see here 1/2
times 2 is 1 but we're getting seven 1/2
times 4 is 2 but we're getting eight so
it looks like we have to adjust that by
adding six more okay so this is what's
called our y-intercept or our initial
condition and this is what the value is
when x is 0 so 0 is like the starting
point but I think for this video and
just to kind of help you to get started
with these input/output tables is look
at the how the Y's are changing look how
the X's are changing it and write a
fraction the change in Y over the change
in X put that number in front of the x
value which is the input and then test
it out and see what adjustment you have
to make you know do you have to subtract
once or add 6 so that you know so that
it represents the the input/output table
so again this is just an introduction
about how to write rules for functions
given an input/output table I've been
working with some students lately in
like pre-algebra algebra and they
haven't really gotten yet into the
slope-intercept form if you want to
learn more about this I'll have a link
for a video that I did on slope
intercept form so you can learn more
I'll see you in the next video